all right what is the thought process in
terms of this infrastructure bill all of
the taxation uh regulatory debate
don't get into the politics i don't care
about the politics but do you think that
it's something where the u.s basically
ends up embracing this or do you think
the u.s is adversarial toward over a
long period of time
no i think we're going to embrace it i'm
actually happy the deal didn't get
rushed through i'm in the camp that says
i'd rather have the policy match the
objectives of innovation and i think the
us should lead in crypto innovation we
should be developing the technology some
of the companies that you showed me
months and months ago are very forward
thinking they need to work in you know
the stuff we looked at together they
need to work in a compliance environment
every single company that wants to raise
institutional capital has to embrace the
regulator and and i'm waiting for it so
i'd rather see policy develop that you
know does not if you're a broker dealer
and you're trading assets you're you
have to go with a certain level of
compliance based on broker dealers that
trade financial assets but if you're a
miner and you're actually an
infrastructure plan mining coin maybe
the regulation should be a little
different for you and i'd rather have
the policy developed with with the you
know the actual industry participants uh
in a way that makes us the global leader
now that china's shutting down all those
you know those miners particularly the
ones that were using coal to burn
electricity this is a huge opportunity
for u.s
and so we should take leadership on
sustainable bitcoin mining and other you
know
all the talk about ethereum and proof
proof of state and proof of work and all
the things that are going on there very
interesting
this sector requires the the regulator
to to
issue policy and once policy is issued
let the competition begin because i'll
tell you a ton of capital is going to be
coming into the space
we've seen in the past in financial
markets and this is a little bit of a
tangent but i was reading about this
over the weekend uh an absolute um
drastic increase in america's position
in the global financial system the more
that we pursue deregulation that comes
with risks
but historically that has been a
positive
do we think that that framework applies
here as well where you basically need
some boundaries of hey this is really
really offside stuff this is really bad
you can't commit fraud no scams you know
all the stuff that is kind of common
sense but within that uh sandbox if you
will the less regulation the better from
innovation experimentation and really
pushing us forward or or how would you
look at that with that historical
context of deregulation in america's
place as the leader on a global scale
yeah that's a good question here's the
way i look at it
you know there's billions of dollars
being invested in d5 all the different
payment solution opportunities all the
different things that can be done around
crypto assets there and that's
definitely where the puck is going and
i'm i've got several bets going on in
that space and pop we haven't even
talked about nfts i mean that's i you
know what do you think about teams
well so let's so let's just think about
that for a second if i'm the regulator
okay and i'm trying to i want innovation
they always want innovation they don't
want to you know stifle innovation maybe
the way i look at it i'm just
speculating on what they might do is
they'll say okay let's do it this way if
there's an off ramp and on ramp with
fiat onto a d5 platform
i got to regulate that because i'm
taking regulated currency
putting it onto a deregulated
decentralized platform but when it goes
back to fiat i want the tax reporting
was there capital gain or loss on the
trade was there interest this is
interest income i want the regulatory
environment to apply to that even though
it's innovation so that i can get a 1099
or whatever i need to do for external
external regulators and i think if the
industry understands what those policies
are and what those rules are that'll
that'll accelerate innovation now when
it comes to nfts i'm going to make a
statement here that you may not believe
but i think that in the next five years
the market capitalization and of the nft
markets will exceed that of bitcoin
itself i really believe that because the
potential for all of these industries
that are you know dealing with physical
assets that want to credit give them
accreditation or give them providence or
sell nfts from that
is billions of dollars it's billions of
dollars from the mona lisa to my watch
collection and so i i look at it and say
to myself
which of those verticals should i become
an investor in and stake my claim and
the one that i'm starting with i haven't
talked much about this i don't think
i've ever mentioned to you is i'm
building a team around the watch
industry i mean
i've been i've been a watch collector
for
40 years i've got a massive build up in
that asset class and i want every single
every single one of my pieces
to have an nft associated with it and i
know all the large collectors around the
world and i've talked to them and they
all want the same thing
it's a multi-billion dollar space
waiting to emerge in the next 24 months
and i'm going to lead the charge there
it's a very arrogant thing to say but
nobody
nobody knows the people i know
in terms of how to put this thing
together but that's just one tiny
vertical so here's my question and you
answered for me
is an nft of a watch
a security
or is it a piece of art
which is it i love you i wouldn't buy it
so i don't have to worry about that but
i know you
would buy it and i bet you you know what
the answer is my guess is uh they would
deem it a security only if the purchase
was made to try to
increase the price you're buying it
specifically for the price appreciation
not for collection or wearing the watch
etc but how do you determine that i
don't know
well that's a very interesting answer
because that's the debate going on right
now because the same thing for art if
you buy a piece of art because let's
let's face it the nft i want to buy
let's say i know a collector named bill
and he's got a one-of-a-kind jp fp
journal watch that i could never have
because it's one of a kind and he's got
three nfts i'm a buyer i'd like to buy
that nft i don't know what it's going to
trade for it's going to get auctioned
but i bet you
in five years it's worth more now that's
no different than buying a warhol right
so
i think we need to get policy on that
meanwhile back at the farm the reason i
want to get all my watches turned into
nfts is i've gone to the insurer and
they said if you can go get them
accredited with an nft and authorized by
the original manufacturer and that
becomes a zero zero zero serial number
to your watch serial number will give
you a discount on your insurance
why i'm because what they're going to do
is say look if we can identify that
watch in perpetuity so when it's stolen
we can simply let the entire world know
that if you don't own that nft your
watch is stolen that takes a lot of
pressure off thieves and stealing
watches if all the world's one-of-a-kind
watches were nft with authorizations
who's going to buy a stolen
one-of-a-kind unless they get the
authorization in ft i wouldn't do it and
it makes the value of the stolen piece
drop dramatically that's why there's so
much rush to do this because right now
even the original papers for old
one-of-a-kind pieces
are forged you can't forge an nft
of a one-of-a-kind patek philly you just
can't and that's why there's such an
interesting opportunity here hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it